paul ronzheimer seit wochen unterwegs in
der ukraine ist jetzt auf dem weg
richtung kiew uns aus dem auto dort
mitten aus dem land zugeschaltet wo die
menschen paul so viel mehr brauchen als
worte schilder uns das
ja patricia genauso ist es die menschen
sagen mir wir können das nicht mehr
hören wir können nicht mehr weitere
solidaritätsbekundung allein dieses wort
hören und worte und gesten und schlagen
nein wir brauchen endlich konkrete hilfe
jahre lang haben wir uns das an gehört
dass ihr uns unterstützen wollte mit
geld meinetwegen ja das ist wichtig aber
das reicht uns nicht das ist das gefühl
hier ukraine sie sagen uns wurde 1994
eine sicherheitsgarantie gegeben von
russland von den europäern vom westen
dafür dass wir unsere atomwaffen
abgegeben haben und jetzt schaut her wo
wir hingekommen sind die ukraine sowie
sie war so wie sie ist sie existiert
nicht mehr eine invasion von wladimir
putin und schon wenige stunden ungefähr
13 14 stunden nach beginn dieser
invasion kann man sagen die ukraine
existiert nicht mehr in ihrer form
mehrere städte sind schon erobert unter
anderem eine großstadt im osten sowie
das ist die ecke wo ich herkam wir sind
hier stunden unterwegs in diesem auto
auf ja kaputten wegen sind immer wieder
im stau weil alle leute oder viele leute
sie hier richtung westen flüchten wie
gehst du wir gehen alle um dich herum
jetzt sind diese nacht bei euch ist es
längst dunkel mit welchen gefühlen mit
welchen aber auch erwartungen
die wir ihnen diese nacht um
weiter für bild live zu berichten und
das mag jetzt ein bisschen pathetisch
klingen aber tatsächlich ist es so dass
die menschen
berichterstattung erwarten darüber was
in ihrem land passiert sie erwarten dass
wir zumindest hinschauen wenn unsere
politik schon nichts tut dass wir
zumindest sagen was ist dass wir sagen
dass wladimir putin lügt wenn er von
nazis spricht über kirchs regierung dass
er lügt wenn er sagt das ukrainische
truppen russland an dass er lügt wenn er
sagt dass es einen angriff dort von
ukrainischer seite gegen die
volksrepublik gegeben hat dass er damit
durchgekommen ist in seinem land
zumindest wenn man sich die umfragen
anschaut das macht viel okarina sehr
fassungslos denn viele haben familie in
dem land ja das sind brüder volker die
sind zusammen so fühlten die ukraine
sich immer und sie verstehen nicht was
dort passiert dass sie wünschen sich
solidarität proteste wir haben das in
den usa gerade gesehen und ich hab
gerade gesehen dass auch eine kleine
demonstration zumindest in sankt
petersburg stattgefunden hat aber
unabhängig davon
geht man mit angst und sorge in diesen
acht man erwartet dass es weitere
angriffe auch auf tiere geben wird die
hauptstadt wir haben erlebt wie
tschernobyl die der ehemalige reaktor
offenbar komplett von der russischen
armee eingenommen wurde das muss man
beschreiben das geht richtung biller
russische grenze ich war da vor vielen
jahren mal und da ist eine art museum
eine verlassene stadt und diese region
hat jetzt offenbar die russische armee
eingenommen in gerade paul konnten wir
den worten von olaf scholz hier lauschen
der seite putin wird diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen hier wirken diese worte auf
dich
diese worte wirken beschämt auf mich
denn putin gewinns gerade diesen krieg
jetzt im moment herr bundeskanzler
gewinnt wladimir putin einen krieg in
der ukraine denn er hat städte erobert
seine flugzeuge sind hier seine
hubschrauber fliegen er gewinnt gerade
diesen krieg und das ist hohn für die
menschen in der ukraine
und wenn dort eine ukrainische flagge
neben ihm steht dann kann ich nur sagen
die ukraine erwarten mehr als das
erwarten mehr als worte erwarten dass
die welt endlich etwas tut und wenn
schon keine waffen geliefert werden dann
doch wenigstens endlich vernünftige
sanktionen das verstehen die menschen
nicht mehr was hier passiert warum
nichts wissen warum ist dieser
zahlungsverkehr noch möglich mit
russland warum gibt es keine harten
sanktionen das sind dinge die hier
diskutiert werden
caparros hatte sich auf dem weg nach
kiew aktuell befindet in der dunkelheit
in der ukraine vor völliger ungewissheit
was da in den nächsten stunden passieren
mag wir wissen dass der flughafen von
kiew links besetztes von russischen
truppen aber wir wissen nicht was in den
nächsten stunden sich in der hauptstadt
in kiew der millionenstadt noch weiter
abspielen wird dank